we've got a voicemail number it is two
one nine two david p and we have a
caller who was weighing in on the recent
Jenga experience let's take a listen to
it
hey David impact I don't know whose idea
was or there was a collective idea for
the Jenga thing but there was something
on that I really wanted to watch it's
seven o'clock
but you're on it seven and I thought but
I want to see if that Jenga tower Falls
or not this time so whatever you're
doing however you come up with those
please yeah ideas keep it up this is
Robert from California just signing off
very good and Robert has fully signed
off yeah people surprised I got a couple
voicemails including one from the Eggman
saying that it really didn't translate
to audio but I would have imagined Pat
that the crashing of the Jenga tower
would have been an interesting audio
moment it is true that it is definitely
more visual than audio slightly more
visual yeah I would say and this was
your idea to your credit it was but I
think to your credit you didn't tell me
it was a disastrous idea because if you
had I might have rethought it so I think
we can both take some responsibility for
what ultimately took place which was the
Jenga game I tragically fell down in the
studio and I think that's what inspired
you as well yeah when Pat fell I thought
there might be something to this falling
down thing that could be used to
generate memberships because nothing's
funnier than falling when people don't
get hurt obviously and that's where I
came up and by the way if we switch to
our other camera Pat people will see
that the Jenga tower has been rebuilt
and it's kind of accompanying me like a
mascot of sorts on the desk although we
don't know what we're doing next we'll
talk about it on an upcoming bonus show
okay a woman has been arrested for
putting an obscene and kind anti Trump
message on her truck and now she might
be filing filing a lawsuit we will talk
about that on today's bonus show we also
have learned that coffee grounds are
being used not to power up producer Pat
but to power up London's buses and also
FoxNews judge Jeanine Pirro
got a ticket for speeding at 119 miles
per hour will she now face the sweet
justice that we've all been waiting for
judge Jeanine to face for her unhinged
rants on right-wing media or will she
use her connections to get out of
trouble all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show two ways to sign up
david pakman.com slash membership and
patreon.com slash david pakman show we
will speak to you on the bonus show it's
a good one today